another episode of the changeling is
upon us and with it a new set of
mysteries in this video we'll be taking
a look at episode 5 and breaking down
all the little details and clues to find
out just what exactly is going on and my
goodness is my brain about to explode as
always I've left timestamps below so you
can see all the topics I'll be covering
now let's get into it for the past few
episodes The Changeling has hinted at
the importance of Norway and episode 5
is no exception we open on a Norwegian
Art Gallery run by Anders nudson fun
fact Anders is played by actor William
cashion who is in the band Future
Islands alongside Sam Herring who plays
William in episode 1 Emma's friend told
Apollo that she met a Norwegian
photographer while traveling in South
America we'll meet this man who goes by
Leaf unbeknownst to him Emma took a nude
photo of herself while he was taking a
leak and only when he was able to
develop the photo did he learn what she
did this was the photo where Emma's
friend said Emma looked like a sorceress
at this time Emma still has on her red
piece of string so she hasn't begun what
could be a body swap with the witch by
the Lagoon but I believe there's some
part of this witch laying dormant inside
her until that moment the red string is
cut and perhaps this photo revealed a
glimpse of that now leaf and Anders also
saw that photo does that mean they've
turned into or will turn into someone
like William who also saw the photo now
Leaf goes on to sell this Photograph to
Anders in Norway where William happened
to be traveling we learned last episode
that William grew up in Norway so
perhaps he was vacationing there with
his family for those of you with a Keen
Eye you can see Willian with his wife
and children way before the big reveal
at the end of the episode by the dessert
stand this is combined with a really
interesting shot where it looks like
some pedestrians disappear through the
mirror this is just a reflection trick
but certainly a conscious Choice by the
director now William takes an even
darker turn this episode as it's
revealed he was the user kindergarten
who posted vile messages on friend more
like like boiling baby Brian this was
sleuthed out last episode since his
profile Avatar was the same as the
necklace that falls off of him after
being knocked down by a cow it appears
that William wasn't always this way it
was only after he laid eyes on Emma's
photograph in Norway that he began to
turn William speaks fluent Norwegian and
as Apollo is taken out from his cell he
says three lines in Norwegian bear with
me here because I used Google translate
and these could be wrong the three lines
are it was fun game of chance and I'm
going to die so they're all pretty
cryptic William also seems to know all
about Cal reciting her real name and
knowing specific details about her past
whether this is some sort of magical
power or glean from his friends who
apparently have access to CCTV footage
is yet to be known according to Cal and
Greta William's wife it was William who
killed their daughter driving him to
Madness in the idea that he can make his
family whole again when Apollo confronts
William we see that he has changed no
longer is he bald and covered in blood
but has turned into his true self which
apparently comes with a new set of hair
but I'm still left with tons of
questions what does William really want
who are these mysterious friends of his
who showed him his true self all that we
really have to go on so far is that he
could be some sort of fairy Apollo's
main reason for visiting North brother
Island was to find Emma who according to
Cal is no longer there not just anyone
can gain access to this island there
seems to be some sort of magical spell
preventing others from accessing it
William remarked that when he went up
and down the river several times he
found nothing in that it was only when
Apollo was with him that the Island
revealed itself Cal even states that
nothing short of a God could access the
island which is a good thing for Apollo
because he often refers to himself as
such
Emma arrived at North brother Island
shortly after the death of Brian she
received help from Cal after messaging a
mother support group and asking if any
other moms felt their child wasn't their
own these women all seem to have
suffered the same fate as her they
believe their child isn't their own and
end up killing them of course no one
would believe any of them thus this
commune for women was established for
their protection and to provide a safe
space where they can be believed Emma
would live here on and off for a few
months sometimes going back to the
mainland to replenish the Island's
library according to Cal Emma willed
Apollo here and it's now up to Apollo if
he so chooses for the truth to be
revealed to him this truth may have
something to do with whether or not
their child was actually killed after
all a mysterious text message that was
sent to Emma says got him implying that
some sort of switch was made and the
thing Emma actually killed was not their
son but something that had been glamored
to look like him I think the answer to a
lot of this Show's Mysteries revolve
around Apollo's parents apparently Emma
talked to Cal a lot about Apollo's
father while she was on the island what
purpose would she have in doing so
there's also this weird connection to
the book to the waters and the wild
which cow says quote tells the truth
this likely has something to do with
fairies wanting to steal his child
Lillian is the one however who I least
trust remember she already lied to
Apollo about divorcing his father but
there's this one weird edit that sticks
out in my mind as Lillian goes to touch
Emma it cuts to the old washer woman
putting the string around her arm almost
as if to suggest there is some sort of
connection between the Washerwoman and
Lillian as Emma's mental health declines
we see certain events from her
perspective her child for example snaps
at her and even morphs his face similar
to that of the puppet in episode 4. this
would suggest that Brian has been
glamored in the closed captioning Brian
is even referred to as the changeling
but knowing Emma's mental state she's an
unreliable narrator and as such it's
also possible this is all in her head
Emma makes three new Wishes the first I
wish you knew me back then which could
be a reference to wanting Brian to see
her before her mental decline the second
I wish you knew a different Mommy that
she is not the great mother for Brian
that she thought she could be and third
I wish she was here who could Emma be
referring to her own mother perhaps the
one who killed herself in a fire I also
want to take a moment to talk about the
carving found in Apollo's jail cell a
carving that reads they bathed it at
dusk they hide it with guile at home in
the forest forever lost in the wild this
reads as though it could be a line from
to the waters in the wild it's also
narrated by Emma implying that it could
have been her who etched it in the
pillar we learned last episode that Emma
was a quote pain in the ass to those on
the island so it's entirely possible she
wound up in this cell for a night or two
if I were to guess what the poem refers
to it would be a child Brian for example
was hid with guile or magic what I found
really interesting was the way in which
Emma posed for the camera now I can't
really show the whole thing or I'll get
demonetized by by YouTube but this is
not your standard look sexy for the
camera pose it's something very
deliberate her right hand faces forward
while the left covers her genitals but
she's not hiding her body as if being
suddenly caught quite the opposite this
is a woman wanting to be seen Emma's
friend notes the strength and power of
this image calling Emma a quote effing
sorceress and as we'll see later both
William and the Art Gallery owner both
men seem hypnotized by it the open Palm
is one of invitation almost as if to say
look at the power of my body given that
Emma will later give birth I wonder if
the left hand covering her vulva is a
nod to the power of a woman I mean I'm
no classical art historian but let me
know what you think below at the
beginning of the episode the narrator
recites in Old Swahili saying quote
whomsoever is not taught by the mother
will be taught by the world this is
interesting because Emma's mother died
while she was young implying that she
had to be taught by the world and as we
all know the world is usually a harsher
teacher than a mother perhaps that's why
she doesn't heed the advice of the
locals and decides to visit the old
Washerwoman even though they warned her
not to those are all the main topics I
wanted to cover in this episode now I
turn it over to you I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember
foreign